- Oh! So should we just
all split it four ways?
- [Second woman] Yeah, works for me!
- [Blonde woman] Cool!
(Ominous music)
(bell gong)
(metallic clang)
- [Second woman] Sounds perfect!
- [Blonde female friend] Cool!
- Yeah...
Yeah. It's great.
Love splitting...
(light jazzy tune)
(unhappy mumbling)
- Do you wanna get Indian food for lunch?
- Yes.
- Okay, uh, noon?
- You can take the pepperonis off right?
- Uh... yeah, I'm not
really hungry anyway.
It's fine.
Yeah, I'll get something else.
- With beef?
- Don't you ever miss bacon?
- Don't you ever miss steak?
- Don't you ever miss hamburgers?
- Can I eat anything here?
Ooo, I could get the...rice.
- Wait, I can eat everything here?
(harp glissando)
- I could never be a vegetarian.
Do you eat chicken nuggets?
- [Waitress] Enjoy.
- Bacon... of course.
- But, where do you get your protein?
- Where do you get your protein?
- Hey, do you wanna split something?
- Yeah, I'm gonna be getting
the veggie entree though...
- Oh, that's fine.
- There's no meat in it...
- Oh, I'm vegetarian.
- Oh, Amazing!
Yeah, let's split it.
- Okay!
- Perfect.
- So, if you're Mexican,
how are you a vegetarian?
You can't be Mexican and
vegetarian at the same time!
Are you a unicorn...?
I don't know what to say. (laughs)